bienvenidos de nuevo en el vídeo pasado
teníamos a 1000 personas que cada una le
debía un millón de pesos al banco y
todos ellos iban a pagar el 10 por
ciento de la tasa de interés anual todos
ellos le habían pedido prestado a este
banco este banco es el banco comercial
que nosotros conocemos pero este banco
lo que hacía era decir lo siguiente
bueno yo les voy a prestar todo este
dinero pero realmente no tengo mucho
dinero por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer
es pedirle prestado también a otro banco
es decir necesito este dinero de vuelta
porque si no mi hoja de balance va a
estar hecha un caos así que voy a juntar
todos estos préstamos y se los voy a
vender a un nuevo banco al banco de
inversiones y ahora que va a ser
entonces este banco de inversiones con
estas deudas y que va a ganar este banco
de inversiones así que déjenme empezar
con una pantalla nueva tenemos al banco
de inversiones agarré un color al azar
pero fíjense quedó verde con el color
del dinero es perfecto para este banco
de inversión y bueno ahora voy a dibujar
a las mil personas que tienen esta deuda
y estas mil personas serán todas yo por
lo tanto aquí hay unos al feo aunque
está sonriente recuerden que somos mil
vamos a pagar una tasa de interés del
10% y bueno todo esto lo recibe el banco
de inversión aunque el banco de
inversión no se está preocupando acerca
de los préstamos o de cuidar los
préstamos o de las hojas de balance más
bien ellos lo que hacen es crear una
corporación ellos crean una entidad una
entidad especial como la quieran llamar
una entidad especial a la que le quedan
poner el nombre que quieran así que
ellos crean una compañía esta gran
compañía que voy a dibujar y bueno lo
que ellos terminan haciendo es dándoles
todos sus pagos a esta nueva empresa
esto quiere decir ellos van a entregarle
a cada una de estas mil personas su
millón de pesos por lo tanto ellos dan
un billón de pesos pero ellos van a
recibir a cambio la tasa de interés es
decir todo el interés que estén
recibiendo lo van a meter en esta nueva
empresa por lo tanto tu interés
el otro interés el otro interés todos
los intereses de todas estas personas
yo mismo es justo lo que va a obtener
esta nueva empresa como capital como
activo y bueno como esta es una compañía
entonces lo que el banco va a hacer es
emitir una serie de acciones de esta
compañía y bueno ya que estamos haciendo
todo de una manera muy simple vamos a
suponer que esta compañía tiene o se
vende en 100 acciones y qué onda con
esta nueva compañía
la corporación entera obtiene los pagos
de la hipoteca de este préstamo de mil
millones de pesos y bueno sé que es una
repetitivo pero recuerden que esta
empresa lo único que está recibiendo es
la tasa de interés o el interés que
están pagando por el préstamo que les
hicieron por lo tanto lo que obtiene
esta empresa de activos son 100 mil
millones de pesos
ojo obtiene 100 mil millones de pesos
durante cada año durante los siguientes
10 años y por lo tanto después de estos
10 años lo que van a obtener son mil
millones de pesos los cuales se van a
dividir en 100 acciones o en 100 caminos
distintos y estoy haciendo todas estas
líneas para confundirte mejor
y bueno por lo tanto cuánto es lo que va
a obtener cada una de las personas que
sean propietarios de una de estas
acciones por lo tanto voy a dibujar aquí
una de estas acciones y cuánto le va a
tocar a cada una de estas acciones
entonces tengo 100 mil millones y
después de 10 años son mil millones de
pesos y entonces mejor en lugar de 100
acciones para que sean más fáciles los
cálculos voy a hacer un millón de
acciones y además esto es mucho más
realista y por lo tanto cada una de
estas acciones va a obtener 100 pesos
por año que fue el hacer la división de
100 millones entre un millón y por lo
tanto en el último año lo que van a
obtener es mil millones entre un millón
lo cual me da mil pesos por cada una de
las acciones por lo tanto no sean nada
mal y lo que hace el banco es vender
estas acciones a todo el público en
general en especial los fondos de
cobertura los fondos mutuos o los
inversionistas de los bonos y bueno
realmente es muy importante pensar en
cómo el dinero se está moviendo el como
el en cómo el dinero va y viene porque
al final cuando se emiten todas estas
acciones
la gente los compra entonces la gente
paga más por ellos es cierto no tal vez
aumente la demanda de este tipo de
acciones o de este tipo de activos y
entonces se obtiene un tipo de ingreso
corriente por lo tanto puede ser que los
inversionistas obtengan no sé en lugar
de mil millones 1.1 mil millones de
pesos por lo tanto lo que hacen los
inversionistas es vender este tipo de
acciones porque están aumentando el
precio en 1.1 mil millones de pesos y
así venden todo este millón de acciones
así que cada una de estas acciones ahora
vale mil cien pesos por acción y
entonces las acciones aumentan de precio
porque cada uno de estos inversionistas
van a pagar mil cien pesos por cada una
de estas acciones y con todo esto se
obtienen 1.1 mil millones de pesos
cuantos 1.1 mil millones de pesos es
como es como un mil 100 millones de
pesos y se dan cuenta crearon esta
entidad de la nada crearon esta compañía
de la nada y ahora tiene un gran capital
y ahora darse cuenta de que ahora
obtuvieron una cierta ganancia porque de
todos estos pagos de la hipoteca
el banco obtenía mil millones de pesos y
ahora hay 100 millones de pesos más y al
final no se está haciendo nada ilegal
porque tenemos nosotros esta estructura
económica completamente armada es decir
esta compañía y al final de todo esto
vamos a obtener una cierta cantidad y
tal vez son un poco desalentador toda
esta cantidad enorme de dinero pero
vamos a hacerla entonces vamos a hacer
las cuentas lo que vamos a tener es un
montón de inversionistas no no no no
perdón no son inversionistas son las
personas que quieren comprar su casa por
lo tanto les voy a dibujar carita feliz
porque quieren comprar su casa y entre
todos van a juntar sus mil millones de
pesos que les va a prestar el banco es
decir cada uno de ellos tiene un millón
de pesos para comprar su casa entonces
retomando lo primero que van a hacer es
ir al banco local y él les va a prestar
esta cantidad y cuando ellos iban al
banco local el banco local les pedía una
tasa de interés fija del 10 por ciento y
después llegó el banco de inversión de
la nada y les dijo yo quiero comprar
los préstamos y por lo tanto lo que pasó
es que el banco de inversiones les soltó
los mil millones de pesos al banco local
y ahora lo que iba a pasar es que tú le
ibas a pagar esta tasa de interés al
banco de inversiones y entonces el banco
de inversiones lo que hizo fue crear
esta nueva o esta rara compañía que le
estaba contando la cual emitió un montón
de acciones de hecho eran un millón de
acciones y entonces lo que pasó es que
estas acciones se vendieron en mil 100
pesos cada una de ellas y se vendieron
al público en general y ahora esta
compañía tiene un activo de 1.100
millones de pesos aquí y está aumentando
el activo y recuerden que esto era
porque todo el pago de este interés se
iba a invertirlo en esta nueva empresa y
después de haber vendido todas sus
acciones habían logrado obtener 1100
millones de pesos y aquí tenemos a todas
estas personas todos ellos eran salman
recuerden que donde había sacado el
dinero la empresa era de todos los
salman los intereses de todos los salman
iban para que esta empresa tuviera un
cierto activo
y entonces seguimos con las cuentas
desde cuenta que ahora hay 100 millones
de pesos más entonces esta compañía creó
100 millones de pesos y esto solamente
por las transacciones esto fue solamente
por haber vendido correctamente sus
acciones y al final todo esto lo crearon
por hacer una cadena de valor y yo te
decía en el vídeo pasado que el final
este banco pudo haber hecho lo mismo sin
embargo él va a sacar una cierta
cantidad de honorarios por haberle
pasado la deuda al banco de inversión y
estas acciones estas acciones que estoy
vendiendo son los famosos títulos
respaldados por hipotecas es decir de lo
que me refería yo en este vídeo y tiene
todo el sentido del mundo pues es un
respaldo un respaldo es una propiedad
que está en esta transacción de esta
compañía y esta compañía tiene el activo
de los pagos que están respaldados vía
las hipotecas es decir si toda esta
gente promete que va a pagar y todos
estos pagos se van a esta nueva compañía
especial y por alguna mala razón
de estos salman pierde su trabajo y por
lo tanto no puede pagar por cualquier
motivo por cualquier razón que se les
ocurra entonces esta compañía va a ir y
se va a cobrar con su propiedad le va a
quitar su casa y es justo por eso que
hablamos de un título respaldado por
hipotecas estamos hablando de que el
respaldo es la propiedad y bueno al
final si no pueden pagar pues lo que se
busca es tratar de vender esta casa y
bueno ya por lo tanto esta compañía
obtiene de nuevo su dinero el dinero va
y viene al final esto es lo que se
refiere un título respaldado por
hipoteca
espero que no los haya confundido
bastante con todos estos dibujos porque
en el siguiente vídeo voy a hablar de
qué son las obligaciones de deudas
garantizadas para qué sirven y en que
afectan o no a las personas